well in public former President Obama
has stayed out of the 2020 race but
behind the scenes apparently he's still
doing his best to shape his party
according to a new report Obama has
promised to other Democrats donors
mostly that if Bernie Sanders begins to
run away with the nomination Obama will
get out there in public and try and
sabotage his campaign but Obama also
isn't willing to support his old running
mate Joe Biden he has refused to endorse
Biden according to Politico Obama told
another Democratic candidate that Biden
lacks any bond with Iowa voters so who
exactly is Barack Obama for what's
really going on here Dana Perino hosts
the daily briefing with Dana Perino and
she joins us tonight right to be in
person it is so nice to be here in your
city of 8 million so um let's just go
through the West so Obama apparently is
not for Bernie Sanders to the point
where he will actually step out and and
try to sabotage him we know that he's
not providing because he hasn't endorsed
well we also knew that in 2016 we didn't
know that that's exactly right we also
know I think to a certainty that he
doesn't like Elizabeth Warren I mean
that's that's well known in Washington
so who does he like who is he for well
it remains to be seen so one of the
things that former presidents try to do
is to stay out of the limelight yes but
you have to be disciplined if you're
going to do that you can't dip your toe
in every once in a while and think that
you can try to maneuver things from
behind the scenes also anybody who's
talking to President Obama they have
they feel self-important so then you're
gonna call Politico or call other
reporters and tell them all I talked to
President Obama and he said this don't
worry he can save us but he can't but he
has one opportunity to be a kingmaker
right at the convention or a peacemaker
if there's a contested convention only
one opportunity if he blows it now it's
a little bit too early I think it's
pretty clear that Biden doesn't have
what it takes in Iowa because that's
just look at the polls like it's not
happening right it's interesting that
we're at this point less than three
months before the first votes in Iowa
and there are still New Democrats
getting into the race yes and they don't
have they can't pull a coalition
together
it's from older people to younger people
to African
Americans and Hispanics white liberals
academics climate change people they
have all these different factions and
that's because they have created them
yes and there's no one right now who can
pull them all together the only person
who thinks that they could do that as a
person who won national a twice Barack
Obama so let me ask you is this a
resolvable because I agree with your
assessment completely is this a
resolvable problem I mean is there in
the available currently available field
of candidates anyone who could in our
imaginations even bring this coalition
together well I think when I say that
Barack Obama could be a kingmaker or a
peacemaker being a kingmaker means that
you can say all right in in my opinion
Barack Obama this is the person who can
pull everybody together and you try to
drive that but I don't know there's
gonna be a lot of resentment in the
Bernie Sanders wing of the party of
which is you know it's healthy it's
vibrant they have stuck with Bernie
Sanders they're gonna be very mad
they're gonna say Oh Barack Obama is
saying this they're the same Democrats
who rigged the thing against me in 2016
Obama spent the last three years making
America better no getting rich by
talking to investment bankers and hedge
fund moguls I mean which is actually
true by the way in striking a deal with
Netflix he has nothing in common with I
would say the Bernie but he does know
how to win two national elections and
that means though then Hillary Clinton
didn't listen to him right the Obama
people were saying you have to go to
Wisconsin you have to do these things
she didn't do those things because she
knew better so I know that you are
deeply skeptical of my brilliant comma
and true comma theory about Michelle
Obama coming in at the last minute tell
me why because I'm right 100 percent
right Michele Obama she does not want to
run for president she has that she's
enjoying she's living her best life yeah
and that the Democrats are still
thinking well we need a savior to come
in even if that Savior needs to come in
it's not going to be Michelle Obama
several months ago I bet you a month's
salary to the charity of our choice that
Michelle Obama will never be a
Democratic nominee for president I know
you look very heartbroken by that
I certainly don't favor her entry into
the race I think she can win you one
other thing
she is very popular right now but the
moment she talks about policy or
politics it would evaporate overnight
okay let's say you're right you very
well may be right you often are mostly
are in fact then who is it I just again
I don't see anybody running for
president as of today who could get the
Bernie people and the finance community
I don't know who it's gonna be and
that's why we keep coming back right the
Democrats will have to figure it out and
it's it's pretty interesting
look America usually gives its
presidents a second term only twice
since World War two has that not
happened especially when you have an
economy like this which remembers that
you were just showing with larry elder
it's gonna be a fight but when you have
the electoral college stacking up the
way that it is in President Trump
already down there in Florida with you
know running away with the show it's
gonna be very hard for Democrats but
they'll come up with somebody then the
left needs to come down you know because
like that could happen and we can't you
know what I mean we we can't lose
content it won't be Michelle Obama okay
Dana Perino great to see you thank you